[Music]
it's been a nice long year for anime you
see this ongoing seasons one blockbuster
of a season but don't you notice
something about it the season is full of
sequels you have third and fourth
seasons as popular series and while
these may be a treat for longtime fans
it begs the question is there anything
in store for newcomers who don't want to
go through previous seasons of
established series have no fear in this
edition of Vinnie tube lists we'll take
a look at some of the top upcoming anime
that aren't sequels without further ado
let's get going and take a look at some
promising shows set to be released in
2020 and beyond we start with so I'm a
spider so what if you think the isso
kind train is about to stop anytime soon
you're gravely mistaken as of right now
we're looking at more on the way for now
we focus on the first of many a Sakai
series to come so I'm a spider so what
you know the Issyk I drill the culprit
this time the battle between the hero
and the demon king in another world
exploding a classroom our protagonist
then finds herself reincarnated as a
spider
yikes what new adventures and challenges
await her in this second life I haven't
read much of the series but from what I
saw in the manga it's enjoyable I
personally think that the humors great
and from what the fan base has said a
lot of cool twists are to come can't
wait to see how everything will play out
in the anime adaptation
there's no airing date yet but you know
it's only a matter of time before we
find it inserted somewhere as the
mandatory seasonal is Sakai series
in ninth place we have inspector for
those craving supernatural mysteries
wait no more from the original creator
of blast of tempest comes this new anime
series inspector tells the story of two
intertwined individuals on one hand is
gothic Oh a girl abducted by yokai in
order to serve as a mediator between the
spirits and human world and on the other
is cool wrote a 22-year old university
student who broke up with his girlfriend
after an encounter with a copper after
this incident God the girl makes her
move wanting to get closer and
eventually marry this interesting
student the two worked together to solve
supernatural issues however God the co
soon realizes that this seemingly
ordinary student is more than he seems
inspector comes your way this January
[Music]
next is the much-awaited anime
adaptation of knobblies noblesse follows
a noble called right going to a deep
slumber and waking up centuries later
may not be the easiest thing to do but
that's exactly what ride does waking up
to a completely different future he
enrolls in a local high school with his
companion Frankenstein together the duo
and some high school friends begin the
quest to uncover the nobles forgotten
past it didn't take long for knobblies
to be one of the most popular web comic
series in Korea admittedly nobody's
getting a full-blown Japanese anime
adaptation is a surprise considering
that the series already appeared as
one-shot videos a couple of years back
guess the demands high for such an
amazing series we don't know the release
window yet but we should have more
information in coming months think
knobblies is the only web comic
adaptation to be featured on this list
well we have another one coming in a
short while
[Music]
up next on the list we take a look at
Darwin's game pseudo can amaze your
typical stock high school student
protagonist he gets invited to try a new
mobile game called Darwin's game despite
knowing that the friend who invited him
to try the games gone missing our
protagonist takes the plunge and finds
himself gifted with powers
turns out Darwin's games actually Battle
Royale where everyone gets powers they
have to fully utilize in order to
survive and unravel the mysteries of the
game sounds like Batum if you ask me
that or maybe apex legends and fortnight
by the way it looks like an enjoyable
anime the manga has been entertaining so
I'd love to see what the anime team can
do for this one survival of the fittest
taken to a literal twist Abe this is a
series to the cow for in 2020
[Music]
almost at the halfway mark with grace
with another assegai title
this time it's Machado Tensei I've known
about this one for a while so it came as
a pleasant surprise to know that Machado
Tensei is finally getting an anime
adaptation truck goons at it again this
time sending a 34 year old NEET to a
world of swords and magic reincarnated
as Rudy as gray rats retaining the mind
of an adult as well as a surplus of
magical powers rudia is a genius in the
making however old habits die hard and
Rudy retains his mind of being a pervert
using his knowledge to make moves on
women in this new life before you raise
the pitchforks let me tell you something
Michelle Goten say is one of the better
izakaya novels out there the world may
seem ordinary but as someone who's read
the novels the world buildings amazing
the main character starts off annoying
and obnoxious but he steadily grows and
discards those traits it might surprise
many given the reputation of yokai shows
but character developments actually one
of the strongest points of Michelle Gore
10 say whether all that translates well
into anime is for us to see Michelle
Curtin say airs next year
[Music]
popular horror title zoo marquee finally
gets an anime after multiple adaptations
across media strange happenings take
place in Carrozza Cho such as suicide
people transforming into snails and
other oddities turns out that the town's
been afflicted by a curse involving
spirals and the two lovers look to find
a way to escape the cursed town the
madness begins and the whole town soon
spirals into utter chaos
looks like our protagonist will have a
challenge getting to the bottom of this
short and sweet yuzu marquise a story
that will leave you on the edge of your
seats it's truly a testament to the
legacy of the series to have so many
adaptations and we can finally see how
an anime adaptation will measure up
against the rest we don't have to wait
for long though for the anime because
2020 is a corner away and it will grace
us with the masterpiece of a horror
anime black comedy a post-apocalyptic
world and insane fun those words
describe Dora Hedorah for me set in the
hole where sorcerers experiment with
their magic Dora Hedorah tells the story
of Chi Minh an unfortunate victim of
magic that leaves him with a head of a
Chi Minh and no memory of his former
life Chi Minh goes on a search for his
real identity of course his methods
aren't quite ethical with a batshit
insane cast Jorah Hedorah looks to be
one hell of a ride especially for
Western fans Mar pars take on Dora
Hedorah looks amazing as of now and I
can't wait for the anime to come out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
third on our list is Pluto first
announced back in 2017 and written by
the legendary NAR okura Sawa Pluto's an
adaptation of a manga based on an astro
boy arc it revolves around gay sacct a
detective who investigates the death of
Swiss robot Mont Blanc in his
investigation he comes to know of an
entity called Pluto as well as a plot to
destroy the great robots of the world
the advanced robots who have the
capacity to become weapons of mass
destruction with the delicate balance
and coexistence between man and machine
mistake jaesik moves to prevent the
worst from happening there's no official
release date but with footage already
being shown it shouldn't be too long
before Pluto graces our screens
[Music]
a few months ago an anime adaptation of
the manga Akira was announced you guys
might know Akira as a movie from the 80s
set in 2019 funnily enough
Akira takes place in Neo Tokyo a newly
rebuilt city after an explosion lays
waste to it over 30 years prior to the
story Neo Tokyo is also the home of turf
wars between rival gangs Canada leads
one of them it's one of the turf wars
that Canada's best friend
Tetsuo finds himself with powers thanks
to a chance encounter with an esper that
escaped confinement developing powers of
his own Tetsuo finds himself the target
of a government that seeks to contain
him it falls to Canada and a group of
people to put an end to Tesla's rampage
this is a series that I didn't see
coming then again with all these recent
remakes of classics I shouldn't be
surprised anymore now should I let's
wait to see whether this series is more
a faithful adaptation of the manga or
not at the summit of the list of top
anime in the future is another
adaptation of a Korean webtoon it's not
just any webtoon is the anime adaptation
of smash hit tower of God one of the
most popular webtoons right now
twenty-fifth pounds a boy who spent his
life of isolation inside a cave
underneath the tower chasing his best
friend rachel bam enters the tower he's
told that he'll get the answers he seeks
should he find his way to the top of the
tower right before coming face to face
with a deadly test grasping on to the
possibility of reuniting with Rachel BAM
keeps going scaling the tower that
continues to provide various challenges
within each floor now the reason why
this tops the list is because I'm a big
fan of the series it's amazing in terms
of world building badass characters and
action it promises a world of adventure
that's made it into one of the best web
comics out there if this series gets a
good adaptation then I truly believe it
would become the next big thing just
like nobodies we don't have the release
window or a PV yet the footage that I'm
showing right now is the promotional
material for the webtoon and the games
there's nothing better to do than wait
for the anime adaptation that will
surely show you why Tower of God has
indeed itself to the hearts of many fans
so what do you say looks like the world
of anime still has a lot to offer even
if you're a new watcher entering this
coming year despite taking the sequel's
away 2020 and the years to come are
still shaping up to be epic for anime
will those years be as good as the
current years only time will tell
which among these mentions series are
you looking forward to the most I would
love to hear your thoughts I'll see you
next time on vide tube